dumbledore is prefect exploring the
chamber of secrets talking to dragons we
harry potter fans love a good theory and
with hogwarts legacy still a ways out
and seemingly no news in sight please
prove me wrong avalanche it's time to
take a look at some of the fan favorite
theories out there and i'll give you my
thoughts on how likely they are to
happen retroreconciler here i'm just a
dad who loves games and the stories they
tell and at number one we have the
theory that it's canceled
wait what how did this one get in here
okay look i get it i decided to include
this one in here because this wasn't the
only person who said this or some
variation of this i definitely think
some people are joking but then i think
there are some people out there who
legit think the game is done the game is
cancelled okay let's just start with the
facts first the game is not
cancelled does that mean that it will
never be cancelled no there's a chance
that any game that hasn't officially
released it could be canceled so yes
hogwarts legacy could be cancelled
however take a look at this tweet from
just october 7th just a week ago which
confirms that avalanche has just hired a
new associate sound designer to work on
hogwarts legacy so they are still hiring
people guys they're still adding people
to the project it is not cancelled it is
still being worked on does that mean it
will 100 never be cancelled no however
right now there is absolutely no
evidence to point to the game being
cancelled whatsoever so it's still
happening don't panic yes we want some
news though number two albus dumbledore
will be our prefect and help us with our
introduction to hogwarts so yes i
definitely think this one could happen i
don't think it will though it is a
possibility given the time frame we've
talked about this a number of times how
the game takes place in the late 1800s
and depending on how late they're
talking about there is a chance that
dumbledore could be at hogwarts now to
be completely honest i would love this i
think it would be
fantastic if you show up at hogwarts and
we immediately have that familiar face i
mean it's gonna be much younger
obviously but we immediately have that
familiar connection to the wizarding
world and maybe we can even learn from
albus dumbledore however the reason i
don't think they'll go down this path is
ultimately i think they want to tell a
new story and i have no evidence for
this is just kind of my gut feel i think
they want this to kind of stand on its
own and dumbledore is a character who
was so
pivotal to the original series and also
the fantastic beasts series that i think
they'll want to be sort of separate from
that they're going to try and do their
own thing as my guess now i would
personally be thrilled with it if he is
in there i'm not going to have any
problem with that whatsoever we've
talked about how the fact that both
fantastic beasts and hogwarts legacy got
delayed they're now coming out in 2022
of course fantastic beasts a little bit
earlier than we thought but now that we
have a title for that the secrets of
dumbledore how interesting would it be
if the game in the movie actually had
some sort of tie-in look i'm not saying
it's gonna happen but i think if they
wanted to blow all of our minds that
would be incredible if they actually had
the movie and the game tie in that
closely with one another number three we
have that hogwarts will be open to
explore and we'll be able to make
relationships with fellow students uh
good news for you my friend because this
one i don't think you can call this a
theory i think you can call this pretty
much fact i mean let's just go straight
to the source directly on the hogwarts
legacy website the first paragraph here
says hogwarts legacy is an immersive
open world action rpg set in the world
first introduced in the harry potter
books now you can take control of the
action and be at the center of your own
adventure in the wizarding world then we
jump down to the very last paragraph at
the bottom discover the feeling of
living at hogwarts as you make allies
battle dark wizards and ultimately
decide the fate of the wizarding world
but when it comes to open explorable
hogwarts and making relationships with
fellow students i think you can consider
that a 100 lock up next we have this one
from jacob which says my favorite theory
is being able to get sent to azkaban it
would be so cool if you got framed or
killed someone and got sent there and
you have to try and escape now this
one's really interesting because of the
fact that we pretty clearly see azkaban
in the original trailer and of course as
a result we fans want to know why why is
azkaban in the trailer will we actually
be going there at some point and if so
why i actually love the idea that if you
commit a crime of some sort that you
will get sent to azkaban however as
multiple fans have pointed out to me
that would kind of sort of kind of
break the canon a little bit if we were
able to escape the first person to ever
escape from azkaban was barty crouch jr
however it wouldn't be known until the
public for 13 more years and of course
we also know about sirius black's escape
from azkaban as well but this is
something where i actually think
avalanche could use some of their
creative freedom remember barty croucher
is the first known escapee that doesn't
mean that there weren't others and also
when you consider the fact that it took
13 years for someone to realize that he
escaped if they're careful with how they
do this in the game they could actually
make it to where it still falls in line
with canon the reason that barty crouch
jr went undiscovered for so long is
because his mother who was already dying
actually convinced barty crouch senior
to use polyjuice potion and then switch
her for her son barty crouch jr of
course the dementors being blind they
only recognize those emotions those
feelings a healthy person a dying person
so they see a healthy person going in
party crouch senior and a dying person
going in mrs crouch and then on the way
out they see again another healthy
person barty crouch senior and also a
dying person now it's very possible that
avalanche could decide you know what
that's canon that we don't really want
to get involved with and yet we still
have this scene from the trailer which
pretty clearly shows that there is
something that will take place at
azkaban so if you have any other
theories on azkaban and why we could be
going there let me know down in the
comments below i have some myself but i
really want to hear from you guys too
number five we have magical creatures so
far the most convincing theory i've
heard about hogwarts legacy is actually
yours i think well thank you the game
will focus on magical creatures and laws
surrounding them and their rights that's
right this is a theory we made a video
on this several months ago and i went
through the trailer and talked about all
the evidence that point to magical
creatures being a very key part of the
plot here we have the villains who are
wearing different fangs and pelts and
the skulls that they wear on their head
and we also know from all the
descriptions of the game avalanche keeps
talking about our ability to tame
fantastical beasts magical creatures are
just all over the wallpaper they're all
over the trailer now maybe it's only a
minor subplot and there's going to be
something bigger going on but i clearly
think magical creatures are going to
have a big role at some point in this
game if not throughout the entirety of
the game if you want to hear the full
theory then check out the little
interactive card in the top right of
your screen but moving on to number six
my favorite theory is that retrorec
contour will be one of the main
characters i really hope it's true i
love that guy well thank you chicken
wings i can neither confirm nor deny if
i will be in hogwarts legacy actually i
can confirm that i will not be in the
game unless i mean avalanche hey just
saying number seven from jiggly wiggly
one of my favorites so far was from
expecto ghost channel fellow hogwarts
legacy youtuber by the way he mentions
that the ancient magic you possess might
be the ability to talk to or tame
dragons okay we know a dragon plays a
big role in the trailer a very large
dragon then we also had the concept art
that released which showed a baby dragon
so again this ties a little bit back
into my theory about the magical
creatures but this one is specific to
that ancient magic is it possible that
the ancient magic we possess could be
the ability to talk to dragons or maybe
even take it a step further the ability
to tame or even control dragons now if
this were the case there's obviously a
lot they can do with this and there's a
precedent for it in the wizarding world
i mean we have parcel tongue which is a
specific ability that lets wizards both
talk to snakes and understand snakes and
i gotta be honest the more i think about
this one the more i like it the more i
think it could actually work i mean
remember how they talk about this is a
secret that threatens to tear the
wizarding world apart like imagine if
you have this power and you decide you
know what okay i'm gonna control all of
the dragons which would basically make
you ridiculously powerful
but in the wizarding world of harry
potter someone who had a power like this
could just completely obliterate the
wizarding world again going back to the
main hogwarts legacy website your
character is a student who holds the key
to an ancient secret that threatens to
tear the wizarding world apart and then
later you possess an unusual ability to
perceive and master ancient magic only
you can decide if you will protect the
secret for the good of all or yield to
the temptation of more sinister magic so
maybe our character can do this yet if
you want to be on the good side you have
to keep this from getting out you can't
let anyone else learn how to do this or
even know that you can do this because
there'd be so many groups who would be
trying to control you if that were the
case and if you're going to be one of
those dark wizards out there then yeah
have fun with the dragons for number
eight we have my favorite theory is that
there is a secret dark wizard cult that
controls everything from behind the
scenes that you get to confront so we
know about the characters in the trailer
that have the mask so it definitely
seems like there is some group or some
organization that is working in what
appear to be like these little caves i
don't know if it's right outside
hogwarts or if this is going to be
taking place somewhere else in the game
but this is something i could totally
see happening you know maybe they're
even trying to influence the ministry of
magic and the laws that are getting made
and this would tie in very well to the
other theory my theory about the magical
creatures and how their rights and all
of that could be a big issue for this
game this sort of dark underlying
organization could be trying to affect
all of that and the last two here kind
of go hand in hand with one another the
first one though if you go down a dark
arts route potentially some form of
tie-in or easter egg with possibly tom
riddle and as they mention here of
course tom riddle is going to come much
later than the time that this is set to
take place so rather than just saying
tom riddle easter eggs on this one i'm
just going to say harry potter easter
eggs in general which i think is going
to be a 100 lock there are certainly
going to be things in this game that i
think avalanche will intentionally hide
for those die hard harry potter fans who
have read the books seen all the movies
to be able to go and find now again
because of the timing i don't know that
it will be anything relating
specifically to tom riddle however the
next theory is that you will be able to
find the slytherin vault now by
slytherin vault i think they're talking
about the chamber of secrets here i'm
not sure maybe there's another slytherin
vault that i'm not familiar with but i
think they mean chamber of secrets here
so again let's start with the facts here
the chamber of secrets will undoubtedly
have been built it's not like it hasn't
been built by this point yet the chamber
of secrets was created by salazar
slytherin in the early early days of
hogwarts so there's no denying that it
will be there the only question is will
we be able to get in will we be able to
explore and what about that basilisk if
you take a look at the harry potter wiki
i thought this section was particularly
interesting here it reads there was
clear evidence that the chamber had been
opened more than once between its
creation and the 20th century when it
was first created the chamber was
accessed through a concealed trap door
and a series of magical tunnels however
when hogwarts plumbing became more
elaborate in the 18th century the
entrance to the chamber was threatened
and was located on the site of a
proposed bathroom the presence in school
at the time of a student called corvinus
gaunt who was a direct descendant of
slytherin explained how the simple trap
door was secretly protected so that
those who knew how could still access
the entrance to the chamber even after
the newfangled plumbing had been placed
on top of it now i know what you're
thinking when did corvinus gaunt live
well the 18th century actually has him
between 1683 and 1783 so the game is set
to take place roughly a hundred years or
so give or take after corvinus was born
so if you're wondering when we see him
in hogwarts legacy i don't think so at
least in terms of a student maybe we
meet him as a really old man but if i go
with my gut feel here guys i do think
that there will be something relating to
the chamber of secrets i don't know if
we'll be able to go in and fully explore
it i definitely think it's possible but
even if we can't go in and fully explore
it i do think there will be at least
some easter egg or something alluding to
the presence of the chamber of secrets
now when it relates to the basilisk
we do know they have insanely long
lifespans over a thousand years actually
and salazar slytherin's basilisk is
ultimately killed by harry potter of
course in harry potter in the chamber of
secrets so if we do have a run-in with
the basilisk safe to say we will not be
defeating it in hogwarts legacy guys i
have absolutely loved making this video
if you enjoyed it as well make sure to
give it a thumbs up let me know which
theory was your favorite as always thank
you all so much for watching i'll talk
to you again soon
[Music]
you